Willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer zum Podcast Dicke Bretter. Wir haben heute einen Gast, auf den wir uns schon sehr freuen. Aber bevor wir den vorstellen, wenn wir ein paar Sätze sagen zu dem Konzept von Dicke Bretter, falls jemand von euch diesen Podcast noch nie gehört hat, was wir nicht hoffen, wir wollen ein bisschen erklären, wie Gesetzgebungen, Regeln, Standards zustande kommen, wie auch die Diskussionen darum verlaufen, welche Institutionen daran mitwirken. Dafür haben wir immer einzelne Beispiele. Dieses Mal war es, glaube ich, ein bisschen überraschender als bei den letzten Podcasts, weil wir uns über Protokolle und Standards unterhalten wollen. Aber dazu gleich mehr. Zunächst sagen wir mal, dass wir im August 2023 sind. Falls ihr das hört, irgendwann, wenn nicht 2090 oder so, dann wisst ihr, wann wir sind. Und wir sagen, wer wir sind, bevor wir unseren Gast vorstellen, nämlich...
Oder ich bin schon dabei, habe ich eigentlich rausgehört.
Genau, zum guten Teil bin ich dabei. Deswegen stellt sich die Frage gar nicht. Aber würde ich noch mal eine Zeitreise machen, würde ich noch mal zurückgehen? Ja, ich würde es, glaube ich, noch mal machen. Gewisse Dinge würde ich sicherlich anders machen.
Also vielleicht wirst du mal als Veteran enden, wie wir die vorhin genannt haben. Irgendwie 25 Jahre IETF, hier sind meine RFCs.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ich habe da keinen langfristigen Plan. Also das ist jetzt weggebunden bei mir. Wenn da die Ziele erreicht sind, dann sind sie erreichbar.
Was würdest du denn jemand raten, der sich auch gerne einbringen will und das schlecht für sich selbst eine Option findet?
Ich würde die Person erstmal ermutigen, das zu machen. Weil das nicht immer so ganz klar ist, wie man überhaupt mitmachen kann. Also es gibt glücklicherweise bei der IETF sehr viel schriftliche Dokumentation, die man auch finden kann.
Das ist ein Wust.
Genau, das ist gleichzeitig der Nachteil. Man ist ein bisschen erschlagen. Man ist auch erschlagen von diesem Formalismus. Und was natürlich auch beängstigend wirkt, das muss man auch klar benennen, sind diese gewachsenen Strukturen, sind demografische Ungleichheiten, sind Hürden, um da mitmachen zu können. Man muss erst mal da hinreisen können, muss die Zeit haben, muss das Budget dafür haben. Und dann eben auch der Umgangsstil kann befremdlich wirken am Anfang. Er ist nicht unbedingt unfreundlich. Er ist im Vergleich zu anderen Communitys auch sehr nett. Aber er kann anschüchternd wirken, in dem Sinne, dass man sich vielleicht nicht traut, da mitzumischen, weil man den Eindruck hat, da sind Leute da, die haben sehr viel Kompetenz. Man selbst hat die nicht unbedingt, man will nichts Falsches sagen, auf so einer Mailing-Liste, von der man gar nicht weiß, wie viele Tausende Leute da eigentlich mitlesen. Und in dem Sinne würde ich die fiktive Person, die da jetzt mitmachen will, nur ermutigen, das trotzdem mal zu versuchen.
Gibt es da so Methoden, Einstiegshilfen, irgendwas?
Also es gibt Einstiegshilfen. Es gibt so Orientierung, zumindest bei den Konferenzen selbst, wo das einem auch noch mal ein bisschen näher gebracht wird. Wie gesagt, man könnte es auch alles theoretisch nachlesen, aber auch da ist die Hürde irgendwo groß, weil man dann nicht weiß, was soll man eigentlich nachlesen und wo.
Und die nächste Sitzung der IETF wird ja auch nicht zu weit entfernt von hier stattfinden. Die ist im Herbst, wenn ich richtig informiert bin, in Prag, also eine schöne Zugreise von Berlin oder von vielen anderen Orten in Deutschland entfernt. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das noch so ist, aber zumindest früher gab es durchaus auch gerade für Leute, die noch studieren oder promovieren, Stipendien von der IRTF, der Internet Research Task Force. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch da noch drauf bewerben könnt, aber tatsächlich, das Finanzielle ist ein Faktor an der Teilnahme. Aber vielleicht gibt es da auch noch Möglichkeiten, die interessierte, potenzielle, fiktive oder reale Interessierte ausschöpfen können, um wirklich da einfach mal reinzuschnuppern. Und ich glaube, auf der Mail-Liste den Mut aufzumachen, ist tatsächlich schwierig, bei so einem Treffen mal dabei zu sein. Das macht es dann schon konkreter.
Ja, wahrscheinlich senkt das die Hürde. Also gut, dass du es ansprichst, finanziell gibt es diese Hürde. Tatsächlich, die Teilnahme kostet einfach was. Das ist günstiger, wenn man es online macht. Aber dann ist es eben auch nicht unbedingt das, was man haben will. Die Kosten werden einem in Sonderfällen wohl erlassen. Aber die Sonderfälle sind relativ wenige, so wie ich das verstanden habe. Also das ist mit einer der Kritikpunkte, dass es diese finanzielle Hürde gibt für Interessierte.
Ich hätte ja noch eine letzte Frage. Das ist ja quasi eine Gerätchenfrage. Kann ich die noch loswerden? Welchen Messenger benutzt du? Ich musste diese Frage stellen. Ich war da schon die ganze Zeit darauf. Und?
Also wir haben noch keinen MLS-basierten Messenger, aber da werden auf jeden Fall welche kommen.
Ja schön, aber welchen benutzt du nun und warum?
Im Alltag verwende ich momentan Signal tatsächlich.
Du hast also deine Telefonnummer abgegeben.
Das ist einer der großen Kritikpunkte. Ich verwende natürlich auch mehrere, einfach weil ich daran interessiert bin, die zu vergleichen und zu sehen.
Hey Lisa, hast du auch die Neunung, er will es nicht sagen?
Na ja, es ist ja auch die Frage mit der Schleichwerbung.
Also die Frage wäre einfach, welchen Messenger verwende ich nicht. Aber sagen wir mal.
Lass mich raten, Telegram.
So, guter Punkt. Telegram versuche ich zu vermeiden.
Wahrscheinlich machst du dich ja auch im Feld auskennen.
Das ist wirklich auch berufliche Neugierde in dem Moment.
Das heißt, du hast so einen Messenger-Zoo auf deinen diversen Endgeräten. Machst ja auch niedlich.
Ja, Raphael, dann wollen wir uns ganz toll bedanken. Du bist ein sehr finnisch, ja, geduldiger Erklärbär. Und hast sozusagen, glaube ich, ganz... Also ich finde jedenfalls den Prozess, den du beschrieben hast, sehr gut verständlich. Und trotzdem, wir so ein bisschen festgestellt haben, dass die Organisation ja noch ein bisschen offener sein könnte und diverser ist, glaube ich, trotzdem ein recht einladender Eindruck, zumindest bei mir, hinterlassen. Also wer sich jetzt so für Engineering interessiert, denke ich, sollte da mal reinschnuppern. Ansonsten empfehlen wir selbstverständlich MLS zur Lektüre. Den Überblick, den die geschrieben haben, der ist doch durchaus lesbar. Also den Problemaufriss und so, den kann man schon verstehen, zumindest nach dem Hören von unserem Podcast, hoffe ich doch. Und tja, dann bedanken wir uns. Und hoffen, dass du unser kleines Podcast-Lehrer, die Dicke Bretter heißt übrigens, weiterhin treuer Hörer bleibst. Und dass du auch in Zukunft Dicke Bretter bohren wirst. Denn so ein Standardisierungs-, oder was der Versuch einer Standardisierung ist, ist ja offenbar ein ordentlich dickes Brett. Aber wirklich.
Ja, vielen Dank, dass ich hier sein durfte.
Tschüss, liebe Hörer, bis zum nächsten Mal.